[ Générique ] A travers les époques, les dangers, une grande aventure les appelle...
[ Générique ] C'est..... L'ÉPOPÉE TEMPORELLE !!
Narrateur : On se retrouve, cher auditeur.
Toujours à la recherche du père d'Iris, nos trois compagnons tombent plutôt sur... Hitler.
C'est vraiment ballot
Et j'ai comme l'impression, qu'il n'est pas du genre à laisser passer des inconnus dans sa bibliothèque personnelle.
C'est comme ça. Les dictateurs n'aiment pas être dérangés,
tout le monde sait ça.
Hitler : *Accent Allemand* QUE FAÎTES VOUS DANS MA BIBLIOTHEQUE ?!
Hitler : HEIN  ?!
Qui êtes vous ?! Avec vos costumes extravagances, c'est pas très "hugoboss" tout ça...
Surtout la jupe est très courte, MEIN FRÄULEIN !
Iris : Oh merde, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Thomas : Eliott, pourquoi il parle avec l'accent ? T'es pas censé le traduire ?
Eliott : Si, mais je trouve ça plus marrant.
Hitler : Quelle est ce personnage métallique ?!
Iris : C'est, humm.. (Hitler : Répondez !) Un... Un modèle de Tank sur pied !
Hitler : (Rire gêné de Iris) Hein...  Un petit Panzer [Tank Allemand] ,  mmh, sehr gut ! Il en faut beaucoup pour gagner contre Staline et les Américains !
Thomas : Et il fait même le café ! Vous en voulez ?
Hitler : Avec plaisir ! (Bruit robotiques) Avec beaucoup de lait ! (Bruit de café qui coule dans un gobelet)
J'aime pas quand c'est trop noir ! (Rire raciste de Hitler)
Thomas : Et, voilà le café ! Vous allez voir, c'est une tuerie !
Iris : Tu sers un café à Hitler ?!
Hitler: Dankeschön! (Merci!)
Iris : Tu sais qui c'est au moins ?
Thomas : Bah oui, je sais qui c'est Hitler, j'suis pas con ! J'ai joué à Wolfenstein, merci.
Et puis, il sait peut-être où est ton père ! Et... (Hésitation), puis là il a rien fait de mal.
Iris : IL A RIEN FAIT DE MAL ?!!
Thomas : Oui et... il a rien fait de mal maintenant et puis... je sais pas, il est accueillant et-
Iris : Mais tu parles d'un dictateur qui décime DES POPULATIONS !
Hitler : Qu'est-ce que vous venez de dire ?
(Hitler sort un Luger P08)
Vous parlez AU FÜHRER ! VOUS VOULEZ GOÛTER UNE BALLE, DE MON LUGER P08 ?!!!
Eliott : Non monsieur Hitler, tout va bien. On parlait de... (Bruit de Robot et changement de voix) Staline !
Hitler : Ooh ! Mon petit Panzer sait parler !
Bon, je laisse couler. C'est bien parce que le monsieur m'a offert un café... AU LAIT !!
Hitler : Sehr gut (très bon), en passant.
Thomas : Holala, comment je viens de nous sauver la vie sérieux !
Hitler : Vous aussi vous êtes là pour me prendre un livre de ma collection persounnel ?!!
Eliott : Comment ça ?
Hitler : Aaah ! Un monsieur en blouse blanche m'a pris un livre juste avant que vous arriviez.
(Petit rire d'Hitler) - Mais comme c'était un carnet insipide écrit par un juif... Je lui ai donné.
Iris : Il parle de mon père là ! (Iris bégaye)
Vous savez où il est parti ?
Hitler : Arf ! Wunderbach (Super) ! Il a disparu sous mes yeux
C'est probablement mes caporaux S.S.
qui m'ont offert un petit spectacle sur-
(Hitler parle en fond)Eliott : Iris, le carnet c'est peut-être une piste ! Il faut causer !
Iris (à Hitler) : Le carnet là, vous pouvez nous en parlez ?
Hitler : Ah ! C'était un cadeau d'un de mes adjugeants, un carnet de note d'un "juif" qui écrit et fait de la science.
(Rire de Hitler : Ahah krkrkrr !)
Hitler : C'était un certain... Einstein !
Eliott : Ton père est venu chercher des notes de Einstein ?
Iris : C'est sûrement pour ses recherches sur le temps.
Iris: Thomas rassure moi tu sais qui c'est Einstein ?
Thomas: Mais bien sur c'est le mec de l'expression: "Je suis pas Einstein moi"
J'le dis souvent
Iris: Ah oui, c'est sur que tu n'es pas Einstein toi
Mais où est-ce que mon père est allé ensuite ?
Eliott : Hitler peut nous aider à savoir
Iris : A... A tout hasard monsieur Adolf
Le Monsieur à la blouse n'aurait pas parlé d'une destination future,
non, non ?  Wie ?
Nein nein
thomas en fond : arrête
Hitler : Aaah Ja ! Juste avant de disparaître
il a dit '' Direction 544 sur l'île de la Réunion''.
Est-ce que ça peut vous aider ?
Iris: Ah benh oui, oui c'est pas mal oui.
Hitler: Je vais ouvrir la fenêtre pour aérer un peu
Eliott: J'ai effectivement un voyage du Docteur Simon à cette période dans mon rapport.
Parfait !
On dépose Thomas à son époque et direction
L'île de la Réunion.
Thomas: Oh non... pas encore, mais je vous suis moi je peux être super utile
Regardez Hitler a failli nous tuer, mais il nous a trouvés
sympathiques, grâce à qui ?
Eliott: Grâce à mon café.
Thomas:  Mais c'était mon idée.
Iris, dis lui que je peux être super utile !
I.. Iris ? Qu'est ce que tu regardes ?
Iris : Bougez pas ...!
*pousse Hitler par la fenêtre* Hitler: AAAAAAAAAAh !
Iris : Ah, ça fait du bien . Thomas: Iris tu viens de tuer Hitler !
Iris : C'est bon Eliott, on se téléporte avant qu'on ait des emmerdes
Thomas: Tu viens de sauver le monde, tu as tué Hitler
Iris: Non pas vraiment c'est
plus compliqué ...
Thomas : Hitler est décédé!
C'est terminé, la guerre, les morts et tout !
Iris : Dans ce monde là
Oui
Mais dans ton époque ou dans la mienne ça ne change rien.
Eliott : Vu le regarde de Thomas, j'ai l'impression qu'il n'a rien compris.
Thomas : Ça va, je suis pas Einstein moi !
Vos trucs de voyages dans le temps '' Les gens meurent, les gens ne meurent pas'' Je suis désolé mais c'est compliqué.
Eliott : On peut changer de temps mais aussi de monde
Il existe une infinité de Thomas comme une infinité de Hitler.
Iris : Regarde ! On revient quelques secondes plus tôt s'il te plait
Eliott: Approchez vous, Retemporalisation Immédiate.
Hitler: Ouch j'ai failli basculer par la fenêtre.
Iris : Et voilà, regarde
On retrouve Adolf!
Et hop !
Hitler: Aaaaaaah !
On le retrouve plus! Ahaha
Et en plus ça soulage.
T'as compris ? Vas-y à toi !
Eliott en arrière !
Hitler : Ah, je vais quand même ouvrir.
Iris: Allez vas-y Thomas Pousses le !
Thomas : Mais je vais pas tuer quelqu'un
Eliott: Il ne sera mort que dans ce monde. Ca n'a aucune importance .
Iris : Et puis c'est Hitler, vas-y, ça soulage !
Thomas :Bon okey. Ju...Juste pour voir . Hum Monsieur Hitler ?
Hitler: Ja?
Thomas : Excusez moi ?
Hitler: Qu'il y a t'il ?
Aaaaaah..
Thomas : Ou.... Ouais ça fait du bien
Et je suis pas un meurtrier ?
Iris : Ben non ! On s'en fout c'est un voyage dans le temps
Thomas : Encore une fois s'il te plait !
Eliott :  Allez une dernière
Hitler: -par la fenêtre! Ah, je vais ouvrir un peu --- AAAAHHHHH!
Thomas : ah ! C'est génial !
Eliott : On a assez poussé Hitler ? On peut y aller ?
Thomas : Oui oui , pardon ... Eh ! Laisser moi venir avec vous ! Juste à la prochaine destination !
Thomas : S'il vous plaît ...?
Iris : Bon ... tâche de rester en vie ...
Thomas : Yes !
Iris : Eliott ? Allons retrouver mon père !
Eliott : Approchez vous , trace temporelle synchronisée, direction "544 sur l'île de la Réunion''.
Eliott : Retemporisation immédiate !
(Voyage dans le temps)
Thomas : Euh ... On devrait pas se retrouver sur une île , plutôt ? Là , on est dans une cabane qui bouge !
Iris : On est dans un bateau , Thomas ...
Eliott : Le voyage dans le temps n'est pas parfaitement précis , l' île doit être juste à côté . ça aurait pu être pire !
Eliott : On aurait pu tomber dans l'eau et mourir noyés.
Iris : Très rassurant Eliott ... Euh ... Merci beaucoup ...
Iris : Bon , on sort de la !
Thomas : (En train de tirer les barreaux)
Thomas : Euh hum ... C-c'est fermé ...
Iris : Comment ça c'est fermé ?? Pousse toi ! (Tire brusquement les barreaux)
Iris : Ah ouais , merde ! On est enfermés !
Thomas : On est enfermé dans les geôles des cales d'une frégate !
Iris : Wow , t'en a du vocabulaire en fait !
Thomas : Ouais c'est parce que j'ai jouer a Assassin Creed "Black flag" . J'ai saigné le jeu ! (En train de renifler)
Thomas : Eh mais , ça sent pas le cramé ???
Laissez moi utiliser mes capteurs olfactifs...
Eliott : (En train de renifler)
Eliott : Oui , ça sent le cramé.
Iris : Mais c'est normal, regardez derrière les barreaux ! Des flammes ! Le bateau est en feu !
Thomas : Oh putain !
Iris : Eliott , téléporte nous ailleurs !
Eliott : Vous allez rire , mais avec votre Hitler que vous avez tuez un paquet de fois , je n'ai plus de batterie pour voyager dans le temps .
Iris : Est-ce que tu vois quelqu’un rire ici ? J'aurais vraiment préféré être téléportée dans l'eau !
Eliott : Je prends note !
Iris : Non non ! Ne prend pas note ! Non ! Oh , les clés ! Je vois les clés derrière les barreaux ! Au bout du couloirs ! Là , sur le burreau ! Regardez !
Iris : Eliott , fais quelque chose !
Eliott : Un café ?
Thomas : Nan mais Eliott ! Avec deux sucres s'il te plaît !
Iris : Nan mais putain !!! Vous ne servez à rien !!!!
Iris : On va mourir ici !!!
Iris : J'aurais jamais du vous suivre !
Aliénor : ... Vous m'écouterez ainsi ! Comment ?! Encore un nouvel endroit maléfique ?!
Iris : Aliénor ! Elle est derrière la grille ! Aliénor ! Coucou !
Aliénor : Oh , nous voilà en enfer ! Je sens les flammes !
Iris : ici !
Aliénor : Ha ! Que vois-je ? Mais vous êtes enfermés
Iris : Les clés !
Aliénor : Hahaha !
Iris : Jette-nous les clés ! E-elle sont derrière toi !
Et pourquoi devrais-je faire ça, Dame Iris?
N'êtes-vous pas dans un endroit que vous méritez?
Iris: *murmures* Oh la connasse
Thomas: Reine Aliénor, écoutez nous!
Iris n'est absolument pas maléfique!
L'occasion d'accéder à votre trône, baah, s'est présentée à elle
Est-ce que vous auriez reculé à sa place?
Non, vous auriez fait comme elle!
Et est-ce qu'elle vous a coupé la tête?
Non! Elle vous a gardée près d'elle, alors pardonnez-la
Donnez-nous les clés, Reine Aliénor, par pitié
Il commence à faire très chaud
Aliénor: Hmm bien, je vous donne les clés...
Mais je vous laisse à votre sort
Et je garde la boite magique!
Iris: CA MARCHE! MERCI ALIENOR!
Et merci, Thomas
Ces clés-là?
Thomas: Ah euh oui
Iris : Qu-QUOI?
Eliott : Les clés non plus...
Iris : Elle s'est téléportée avec les clés?
On est foutus ! On va mourir !
Thomas : Oh merde merde !
Eliott : Iris a raison.
Thomas : Putain on va mourir !
Eliott : Nos chances de survie sont proches de...
1 %
Thomas (chantonne) : Libéré, délivré...
Iris : Oh mais arrête avec cette chanson à la con !
Thomas : Ok, désolé, c'était pour détendre l'atmosphère...
Inconnu : QU'AI JE ENTENDU ? UNE CHANSON ?
Ya t'il des âmes à secourir dans ce bateau en flamme ?
Iris : ICI !
Inocnnu : Mon Dieu !
Inconnu : J'arrive tout de suite !
Eliott : Tiens, voilà le... (change de voix) 1%.
Inconnu : N'ayez crainte , je vais ouvrir cette porte à l'aide de ma force !
Reculez-vous ! Je prends un peu d'élan...
Personne n'est blessé ?
Iris : Oh merci ! Vous nous avez sauvé !
Inconnu : C'est normal !
Je parcours les terres et les mers pour secourir les personnes en danger !
Vite ! Sortons d'ici !
(CRI RAUQUE)
Thomas : Oh ! Et lui, c'est qui ?
Inconnu à la voix rauque : En voilà un qui a goûté à hache !
Et j'en vois trois autres qui veulent être découpés en morceau
par le célébrissime pirate La Buse.... Ahahahah!
Narrateur : Qu'est-ce qui est mieux ? Être enfermé dans un bateau en feu ?
Ou se retrouver face à un pirate sanguinaire
dans un bateau en feu ?
Pas besoin de choisir pour Iris, Eliott et Thomas, ce sera la hache
du pirate...Rendez vous au prochain épisode
pour savoir en combien de morceaux ils seront découpés !
Cyprien : Merci d'avoir écouté le quatrième épisode
de l'Épopée Temporelle, n'hésite pas à t'abonner et à mettre un pouce
en l'air et à la semaine prochaine !